[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
discuter et débattre des sujets
d'actualité à leur mobilité durera deux
mots de plus en plus présents dans notre
quotidien
la mobilité durable consiste à
satisfaire la liberté de déplacement des
personnes tout en cherchant à diminuer
l'impact des moyens de transport
utilisés sur l'environnement
comportement personnel des entreprises
et des collectivités et ce aussi une
alternative au tout voiture on en parle
avec nos invités jean baptiste à monique
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge des
transports et de la mobilité sophie
stefan bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
responsable responsabilité sociale des
entreprises de la banque populaire val
de france et xavier de la porte bonsoir
bonsoir à vous êtes animateur au club
climat énergie de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors je voudrais commencer avec vous
jean baptiste à monique puisque le
vendredi 7 mai dernier c'est le plus
récent l'agglomération inauguré un
service de trottinettes électriques
c'est une nouvelle étape dans les
solutions alternatives proposées par
saint quentin en yvelines
oui tout à fait comme vous le savez
saint quentin en yvelines est un
territoire d'innovation notamment sur
les mobilités sur les transports après
très récemment le véhicule autonome sur
lequel nous reviendrons à peut-être ce
soir vous avons effectivement inauguré
avec l'opérateur tire un service de
trottinettes électriques sur l'ensemble
des douze communes de l'agglomération
la nouveauté c'est que c'est la première
fois que nous avons une telle
expérimentation sur un territoire qui
est aussi un territoire périurbain donc
avec mille engins et plusieurs plusieurs
dizaines de stations plusieurs centaines
de stations même se sont déployés
aujourd'hui sur les douze communes de
l'agglomération
ça répond à un enjeu majeur aujourd'hui
qui est l'enjeu des déplacements courts
notamment dans les logiques du premier
au dernier kilomètre un chiffre juste 65
% aujourd'hui
des trajets en ile-de-france soit moins
de 3 kilomètres donc on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'une solution souffle et
durable
la trottinette peut venir apporter une
solution complémentaire aux besoins de
déplacement de saint quentinois xavier
de la porte on a entendu parmi les
avantages il y à ce parcours très court
elle est aussi longtemps une image un
peu négative la trottinette celles liées
au comportement de certains usagers et
de la relation avec les automobilistes
ou les piétons est ce qu il yad autres
avantages à la trottinette et bien moi
j'en vois un très bien qu'ils aient la
collection avec le service de ce qu'ils
cherchent
nous avons lancée fin 2001 puisque en
fait ce projet là aussi ça à relier
différents entreprises en proposant une
flotte mutualisée de véhicules la seule
chose c'est que vous rejoindre les
stations d un général la fta souhaite à
cinq minutes à pied mais ça veut dire
que grâce aux comptines est où pourra
étendre un petit peu les distances et
permettent finalement à des entreprises
qui sont un petit peu plus loin que le
centre de saint quentin aujourd'hui on a
commencé ce qu'ils cherchent de
rejoindre assez facilement une station
ce qui gère donc voilà j'ai testé deux
minutes de trottinettes et hop on est
sur la voiture ce qui est cher et on
peut partir après près de dix ans
beaucoup plus longue alors on a à nommer
les navettes ski fier on va y revenir on
a du temps dans l'émission je voudrais
déjà qu'on passe aux sondages saxe
chaque semaine on propose à nos
téléspectateurs de voter sur une
question
on voulait savoir ce qu'il pensait à
propos du tout voiture est ce qu'on peut
un jour s'en passer et c'est le nom qui
remporte les suffrages avec 71%
est ce que c'est une réponse que vous
comprenez un jean baptiste à monique oui
je la comprends et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il faut pas aujourd'hui opposer les
différents modes de mobilité entre nous
on aime à parler à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de bouquets de
services de bouquet de solutions pour
les déplacements pour les mobilités
évidemment si en avançant sur
l'innovation sur les mobilités durables
que ce soit des mots des mots des actifs
les modes doux ou des infrastructures en
tout cas des transports plus structurant
plus plus lourds comme comme on le dit
sur sur le bus et le train on arrive à
diminuer la part modale voiture ce sera
ce sera bénéfique mais il faut pas y
aller à marche forcée je crois qu'il
faut l'accompagner et d'ailleurs
l'initiative qui est porté par le club
climat énergie mais aussi avec les
entreprises sur sur le ski cher
on est sur du véhicule automobile mes
propres électriques et je crois aussi
que l'avenir s'ils se situe là c'est à
dire développer aussi des automobiles en
tout cas la voiture électrique dont on
parle aussi assez souvent
moi je crois que je comprends ce chiffre
parce qu'aujourd'hui comme je le disais
il faut pas on ne peut pas imposer sur
tout dans un territoire comme les nôtres
en grande couronne l'interdiction de la
voiture je crois que ça n'a pas de sens
certains s'y sont testés en petite
couronne même à paris et on voit bien
que ça me suicide pas aujourd'hui à des
gens donc avancer sur la transition
écologique et la transition énergétique
notamment dans le domaine des mobilités
évidemment oui et c'est ce que nous
faisons
il faut y aller progressivement et il
faut aussi se pencher sur la question
des énergies renouvelables et de toutes
les énergies qui viendront alimenter les
transports innovants pour demain
justement vous avez nommé notamment les
entreprises sophistes et fo au sein de
banque populaire val de france
les collaborateurs sont sensibilisés et
poussée soit délaissé la voiture ou tout
du moins à la diminuer notamment co
voiturage vous pouvez nous expliquer un
petit peu effectivement je partage aussi
tout à fait des propos de jean baptiste
à monique est la mobilité est vraiment
plurielle en fait il faut surtout aller
progressivement et avec des offres tout
à fait complémentaires et la banque
populaire val de france on aime bien les
innovations aussi on aime bien les
esprit d'initiative et ce sont d'abord
des entrepreneurs et dans ce cadre là on
a travaillé c'est vraiment avec beaucoup
de directions qui ont cette mobilité au
coeur de leur sujet en impliquant les
collaborateurs en impliquant tous ceux
qui raillent à distance donc le domaine
numérique a son rôle à jouer et aussi le
domaine question de la mobilité au
travers des voitures et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a mis en place un
système d'auto partage un système de
voitures en écho partageant une plate
forme d'écho partage intégrée à la
banque il ya plus de 400 collaborateurs
et cinq éditeurs qui sont qu'il utilise
on a aussi mis des vélos dans des
agences en test notamment dans des zones
très urbaine parce que l'art
effectivement le déplacement pour des
rendez-vous qui ont peut-être peut-être
une problématique donc le vélo
électrique à moins d'une réponse
on a donc cette petite forme d'écho
partagez le le projet ski cher qui
étaient cités tout à l'heure où là on
est vraiment en inter entreprises et en
innovations de mobilité inter entreprise
qu'il a été un nouveau service qui vient
compléter l'offre et qui plaît de plus
en plus justement ceux qui cherchent à
en parler pour la nommer plusieurs fois
et plus que je me retrouve excusez moi
il ya dix sept mille établissements
entreprises qui sont recensés sur le
territoire en septembre 2020 c'est ce
fameux ski cher un service d'autopartage
et xavier de la porte comment est-ce
qu'il a été pensé
ce système vous savez dans le cadre vue
du club climat énergie on a des groupes
de travail sur différentes thématiques
le principe du club c'est de pouvoir
partager des réflexions avec des acteurs
qui sont plutôt des sachants et a
ordonné on l'est évidemment partenaire
privilégié de saint quentin en yvelines
dans nos réunions on a émis ce besoin de
partager des véhicules et de voir
comment on allait faire le covoiturage
était par ailleurs déjà lancé dans
différentes entreprises
on sait dire modèle finalement et c'est
les autres
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas au travers
d'entreprises et notamment dans le
centre de saint quentin ville nous a
volés ont trouvé ce qu'ils sont proches
les unes des autres
créer un service d'autopartage à des
entreprises alors dans la réalité ça a
mis à peu près deux ans pour le faire
donc c'est relativement long avec
beaucoup de réunions je peux même vous
citer un chiffre 3500 heures ont
accumulé les gens sont des acteurs de
travail donc c'est quand même
significatif
finalement pour aboutir à un projet qui
fonctionne qui a été lancée donc en
octobre 2020 avec une flotte de dix
véhicules hors des véhicules propres
électriques ce sont des dd nissan leaf
et puis des véhicules hybrides se sont
aidés des corolla mais l'idée c'était de
répondre aux besoins des entreprises ont
d'une part de situer les stations qui
soit vraiment proche du siège et une
station qui est juste à côté de la
banque populaire val de france qui est à
côté
non pas qu'il ait partir du projet il ya
une station est également juste à côté
d'une église qui est un autre partenaire
du projet la station bon populaire et
partagé également par par leoni est donc
ce qui est très important c'est que août
on peut prendre le véhicule électrique
pour des vies pour les distances
relativement courte
mais si je prends l usage peut être que
même ces fonds pourra le confirmer mais
l'usagé par et vous le salarié de la
banque populaire ou de leoni qui va qui
vont le temps en temps l'allemagne pour
le noir lusage véhicule électrique n'est
pas encore évident donc ça permet de
grâce à skis cher de dire à la fois je
peux choisir le type de véhicule
doit-il être électrique ou hybride et
puis surtout pas ça permet de mutualiser
cette flotte là entre trois entreprises
et donc d'optimiser le nombre de
véhicules et surtout le nombre de
kilomètres et donc d'avoir un service
complémentaire au service de mobilité
qui existe et puis qui finalement d'un
point de vue compétitif la plus
économique est très compétitif j'ai vu
que madame stephen chamanique voulait
réagir je vais d'abord donné la parole à
monsieur à monique qu'est ce que ce
qu'ils cherchent et sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
il y à d'autres zones d'activités est ce
que c'est un service qu'on pourrait voir
se voir de voir se développer sur
d'autres zones d'activités à bas en tout
cas évidemment c'est notre souhait mais
ça me permet de cible le souligner un
point important et je crois que madame
stefan abondera aussi en ce sens
moi je crois aujourd'hui qu'il faut
surtout pas non plus on disait il faut
pas opposer des types de mobilité entre
eux il faut pas non plus opposé le
public et le privé
on est complémentaires et en
fonctionnent ensemble et on le voit sur
une initiative comme celle ci comme sky
cher évidemment les entreprises son
moteur et nous collectivités admiration
on est en soutien et en accompagnement
d'ailleurs vous avez une initiative qui
verra le jour prochainement
c'est cette annonce vous savez de la
software république avec cinq grandes
cinq grandes entreprises je pense à
dassault systèmes france atout france à
thales qui va travailler sur la mobilité
du futur
sur l'innovation justement sur la
mobilité durable et la mobilité en tout
cas dans mon quotidien pour l'eau pour
nos concitoyens
donc oui je juge moi j'insiste vraiment
et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est dotée aussi
à s'implanter en yvelines d'un plan de
déplacement inter entreprises
monsieur laporte justement y contribuer
avec avec le climat c'est des synergies
aussi qu'on souhaite créer qu'on
souhaite bâtir et qu'on souhaite
pérenniser entre le monde de
l'entreprise le monde économique
qui a aussi des ressources que nous
n'avons pas il faut le dire même en
cette période de crise et je crois que
notre action est complémentaire et qu'on
arrivera à proposer toujours et encore
des solutions mobilité qui s'adapte aux
nouveaux besoins qui émergent dans notre
société si on travaille ensemble donc
c'est très important et c'est pas pour
rien pour donner la parole justement
comme ça va ne défend que l'essentiel en
tout cas les dernières inaugurations que
nous avons pu faire ont eu lieu
justement à la banque populaire val de
france
c'est un symbole mais plus qu'un symbole
ça montre aussi cette cette envie et ce
partenariat qui existe vraiment entre le
public et le privé
mais dan steffan justement qu'est ce qui
a intéressé la banque populaire val de
france a participé à ce projet y en a
d'autres mais un soutien notamment que
j'ai peut-être pas du tout à l'heure
mais on avait déjà depuis plusieurs
années à une politique de mobilité
portait justement par l'accompagnement
de tous les partenaires notamment du
club quel climat énergie d'avoir une
politique forte en terme de mobilité et
nous avions déjà fait évolué fortement
notre parc de véhicules en libre-service
au sein de la banque pour les
collaborateurs puisqu'aujourd'hui nous
avons quasiment tous nos véhicules qui
sont propres hybrides ou électriques et
je le partage tout à fait l'électrique
c'est pas gagné encore donc en quelques
freins et on veut bien l'atout des
véhicules hybrides est par contre notre
offre forcément est limité quelque part
à la contrainte de l'ouverture du siège
il ya une souplesse qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui avec notre parc que l'on a
par contre de façon très forte avec ce
qui faire c'est évident non seulement on
optimise les moyens on rationalise les
coûts et en plus on offre à nos
collaborateurs plus de sécurité parce
qu'au début les véhicules sont de très
haute qualité et avec en plus cette
souplesse d'utilisation et de quels
usages que nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
avec le parc en libre service
donc c'est vraiment gagnant gagnant et
c'est grâce à la collaboration comme
voulait ni de partenaires de terrain
d'acteurs de terrain qui sont allés
style engagé mobilisés guillem relever
les défis et qui naturellement non plus
que accompagner l'action de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
et c'est vrai que c'est pour ce qui est
cher mais je sais qu'on a aussi un peu
contribué à l anr est autonome et voilà
où nous en sommes ravis
alors le 10 mai 2020 le forfait mobilité
durable à et or est entrée en vigueur
c'est une prise en charge facultatif par
l'employeur des frais de transport
personnel entre le domicile et le lieu
de travail jusqu'à 500 euros par an il
ya plusieurs moyens de transports qui
sont concernés on le voit à l'écran les
lots qu'ils soient électriques ou non la
voiture dans le cadre d'un covoiturage
les engins de déplacements personnels ou
en look en location en libre service ou
encore les transports en commun en
dehors des frais d'abonnement et xavier
de la porte c'est aussi une nouvelle
étape pour la mobilité durable donner
les moyens à ceux qui n'en auraient pas
oui absolument et puis comme le disait
monsieur malek je pense qu'il faut
vraiment maintenant de plus en plus de
réfléchir et globale prendre du recul il
n'y a pas un moyen de transport il ya
plusieurs moyens de transport et les
pros volant que c'est moins transport
vont s'additionner
vous savez je crois que la réflexion
assez c'est presque notre devoir c'est
penser d'abord à l'usagé aux usagers
aujourd'hui c'est de réfléchir
finalement comment on fait pour aller
d'un point a à un point b et de trouver
les moyens qu'ils soient les plus
optimisées pas toujours là point de vue
technique mais ça peut être aussi des
moyens humains de respecter le les temps
les coûts et puis surtout le zéro
carbone
ça c'est un élément important donc un
poids associe des vélos pouvoir associer
des trottinettes pouvoir associer des
véhicules en courte durée et derrière
avoir des systèmes de subventions qui
vous d'elle qui vont permettre de
réduire les coûts je crois que c'est un
élément je pense que le public d'un
général qui soit finalement salariés ou
où le public est demandeur de ce genre
de début de solution donc je crois que
ça va ça va tout à fait dans le bon sens
et simplement je rajouterais un élément
il faut savoir que dans toutes ces
solutions là il existe aujourd'hui des
certificats d'économie d'énergie que peu
d'entreprises ou peu d'acteurs sollicite
et qui permettent quand même de réaliser
des économies d'eau qu'on est
directement dans la stratégie
aujourd'hui
finalement des accords des accords de
paris vers une mobilité évidemment
durable mais aussi vers une innovation
et du coup ce partenariat que nous avons
avec 50 ans je dirais qu'il est plus que
fondamental il est nécessaire et et on
est ensemble pour gagner ensemble entre
donc le club les entreprises est
évidemment 50 ans les villes quand on
parle mobilité durable c'est vrai qu'on
a tendance à vite pensé au vélo et sur
saint quentin en yvelines depuis 2010
est il y à une vélostation un jean
baptiste à monique elle a du succès les
vélos s'arrache
oui effectivement alors surtout quand et
je rejoins ce que disait monsieur
laporte parce que il va falloir aussi
tenir compte de la période que nous
traversons actuellement et des
conséquences qui doha sur les habitudes
et sur les sur les déplacements
on sait que les comportements va évoluer
on sait que de nouveaux besoins en
s'exprimer et donc même on pourrait
parler du télétravail on pourrait parler
des déplacements domicile travail qui
vont évoluer et donc dans cette logique
là il faudra évidemment qu'on s'adapte
et qu'on se réinvente
oui sur la vélostation après le
déconfinement on a eu une offre
promotionnelle et les vélos sans partis
comme des petits pains on a aussi
quelques vélos électriques qui sont ils
ont tous été réservés
donc c'est très positif c'est très
positif après le sujet aujourd'hui sur
le vélo on peut avoir des offres on peut
proposer des vélos à l'application
c'est aussi le sujet des infrastructures
et des itinéraires cyclables et ça c'est
aussi c'est un chantier que nous lançons
nous avons aujourd'hui un schéma
directeur cyclable qui date de 2009 qui
représente à peu près 420 km
d'itinéraires cyclables sur le
territoire de l'agglomération ma part
modale bello aujourd'hui sur saint
quentin en yvelines est d'à peu près 3%
notre ambition et nous porte nous la
portons avec un nouveau schéma directeur
cyclable nous allons pouvoir présenter
dans très peu de temps
c'est à minima de doubler cette part
vélo et d'imaginer en tout cas de
nouveaux itinéraires résorber aussi
certaine discontinuité sur l'ensemble
des douze communes
ça c'est un chantier important mais on
est prêt avec le département avec la
région aussi qui va découvrir de glaire
leur vélo en tout cas avec l'ensemble
des partenaires
nous sommes prêts à mettre quelque part
les moyens qu'il faudra pour que la part
modale et l'on puisse augmenter et que
le vélo apparaissent comme une mobilité
du quotidien et j'ajouterais même une
mobilité du quotidien sécurisé et
sécurisante à la fois pour l'utilisateur
des utilisateurs en devenir mais aussi
pour l'ensemble des acteurs de la route
qui se partagent l'espace public le
réseau public partagé il ya une
nouveauté aussi depuis quelques mois
c'est la navette autonome vous l'avez
déjà tous un petit peu dit c'est la lune
490 sur un peu plus d'un kilomètre entre
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à la zone d'activités du pas du
lac
en quoi est-ce qu'elle rentre dans la
mobilité durable en quoi est ce qu'elle
est aussi différente peut-être du
transport en commun du bus comme on le
connaît aujourd'hui
jean baptiste à monique alors cette
navette autonome
c'est la première fois en tout cas cool
expérimentaux en circulation ouverte
c'est à dire que c'est la première fois
que cette navette autonome et tester en
conditions réelles avec vous voyez sur
sur vos images avec d'autres d'autres
acteurs de la route comme les
automobilistes qui passent pas loin
comme les piétons et ça c'est très
intéressant pour nous aussi doté de
tester cette technologie là on parle et
on disait que la voiture électrique
était pas encore forcément au point pour
être démocratisée très largement qui
avait encore un peu de travail est
évidemment accords aussi un peu de
travail sur véhicules autonomes mais en
tout cas c'est une solution de mobilité
qui est assez souple et puis qui vient
encore une fois complété compléter des
solutions qu'on peut développer sur sur
un territoire comme le nôtre mais encore
une fois ça c'est un partenariat qui a
été menée avec ile-de-france mobilité et
puis avec les entreprises et madame
stefan pourra évidemment on va compléter
parce qu'on sait que ils ont été 1 un
acteur moteur en tout cas sur sept sur
sept l'expérimentation
la parole est à vous madame stefan c'est
justement la banque populaire val de
france et aussi dans ce projet qu'est ce
qui vous amène à se motiver
c'est toujours le côté innovation je
trouve que là la navette est
exceptionnel on l'a on l'a accueilli
dans notre parking notamment pour
justement le favoriser ces essais on a
mis également notre bornes électriques à
disposition
donc c'est le petit voilà le petit
d'accompagnement qu'on a pu faire et
c'est vrai que l'on vous remercie encore
beaucoup d'avoir nous avoir permis de
mener cette inauguration sur notre
parvis devant donc avant plusieurs mal
de français et cette navette oui on a
hâte de la voir
on ne sait quel toujours un petit peu en
expérimentation sans doute mais on a
vraiment hâte de l'avoir parfaitement
alors en marche parce qu'elle est je
pense qu'elle va vraiment rendre un
service extraordinaire à l'ensemble des
usagers de saint quentin
il ya une actualité qui a bouleversé la
notion de transport c'est bien sûr la
crise de l'aco vide et xavier de la
porte
le tout voiture est un peu revenu on le
on s'en est rendu compte ces derniers
jours sur la route on reprend sa voiture
mais il ya aussi
la marche à pied et les vélos et les
trottinettes électriques est ce que
finalement la commune va peut-être faire
réfléchir sur ces transports
probablement que probablement que oui
vous savez dans une voiture on peut être
une fois thierry cardon qu'on peut faire
c'est les places étaient un peu en
trottinette vers le coffre des trois
l'admettre mettre à notre tête l'idée
c'est vraiment de d'être capable de
d'avoir plusieurs mois de transport je
crois que de plus en plus les gens
recherchent ça et même si elle a commis
et qui évidemment pendant un certain
temps peut-être y aura des retours à ce
genre de choses je crois pas que ça dure
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est inscrit
dans une pré transformation des usages
et que ça va continuer aujourd'hui par
exemple si je prends sur ce qui est cher
c'est vrai qu'on a un taux utilisation
qui est de l'ordre de 30 35 % mais on
est persuadé qu'à partir de septembre à
partir au moment où les gens reviennent
sur leur lieu de travail
et de toute façon ça sera comme ça et
peut être humain qui aura plus de
mobilité
de deux choses l'une où ils ont le choix
de désirs je prends ma voiture puis je
fais des allers-retours domicile travail
ou alors est solide finalement je peux
me déplacer pour moi j'en ai envie parce
que je sais que j'ai une voiture de
disparus ou parce que j'ai une
trottinette ou parce que j'ai un vélo et
j'ai pas besoin de prendre la voiture et
je crois que c'est ça que qu'on
recherche pour nous les gens c'est ce
confort et ses capacités être sûr qu'à
un moment donné ils pourront bouger en
fonction de leurs besoins
il a je crois que en plus par rapport à
la typologie du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines et des innovations
qui sont portés on est exactement dans
ce cas de figure est encore beaucoup de
choses à faire mais on est je reste
persuadé qu'on est dans le bon dans le
bon sens et que même après 2002 il y
aura encore beaucoup beaucoup de shows
duc de choses à faire
alors selon une étude de l'institut ifop
20% des actifs ont changé leurs
habitudes leur soit par une initiative
personnelle ou sur la demande de
l'employeur
sophie stéphan au sein de banque
populaire val de france est-ce que vous
avez proposé aussi des aménagements qui
vous ont été dictées on va dire par la
crise de l'accueil vide
en introduction aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on ait tous enfants et je crois qu'on
a tous cet objectif commun c'est de
réduire l'empreinte carbone et le
contexte de la pandémie a fait que on a
évolué dans notre mode d'activité notre
format d'activité au travail notre
relation travail naturellement nos
déplacements et c'est la conséquence et
nos collaborateurs on les a on leur a
permis de
et bien d'avoir ces nouveaux sets ces
nouveaux moyens de travailler forcément
l'impact des trail a fait que on a
réduit fortement notre mobilité donc ce
qu'on sait en tout cas c'est qu'au
niveau 2 depuis trois ans on a réduit de
presque plus de 30%
nos déplacements nos gaz à effet de
serre liées aux déplacements donc c'est
quand même assez considérable mais c'est
aussi la conjugaison de plusieurs
actions il y a il est le vélo j'en ai
parlé pour la relation avec nos clients
dans les zones urbaines mais aussi on a
fortement incité nos collaborateurs à
utile à utiliser le vélo en mettant une
politique de remboursement des limites
et que les métriques incitatives
notamment pour le vidéo mais également
pour usage des véhicules invitation ne
pas utiliser juste devant son véhicule
personnel au profit du parc les gros
service et de ski cher qui lui
complètement accessible et je termine
législation tant que ce qui est cher
pour nous demain la prochaine étape
c'est peut-être de permettre à nos
collaborateurs de les utiliser en dehors
de l'activité professionnelle sur le
temps d'un week-end et là c'est vraiment
je dirais le gain la plus value d'un
service d'autopartage interentreprises
jean baptiste à monique vous souhaitiez
réagir oui parce que vous savez en
matière de déchets en dix meilleurs
déchets c'est celui qu'on ne produit pas
et quelque part quand on parle de
transition écologique aussi et de climat
le meilleur déplacement aussi c'est
celui qu'on ne fait pas et c'est pour ça
que je crois que qu'on parlait de
l'évolution des comportements tout à
l'heure moi je crois beaucoup aussi sur
un nouvel usage des gars et je crois que
en tout cas sur toutes ces
infrastructures où vous avez gare
routière gare ferroviaire vous avez
justement des départs de mobilité il ya
déjà eu en amorçage sur ces questions là
il va falloir qu'on regarde comment on
peut aussi proposer des solutions
notamment sur des tient lieu notamment
sur des espaces de coworking pour aussi
limiter le nombre de déplacements
domicile travail
il ya aussi un train une réflexion à
avoir sur les plages horaires on n'est
pas forcément tous obligés d'aller se
mettre sur la ligne 13 entre 7h30 et
8h30 tous les matins donc il ya des
réflexions aussi comme ça ça vous le
verset comportement ça me bouleverse le
comportement de nos concitoyens des
entreprises des collectivités des tas
mais je crois qu'on peut
un petit mot pour aussi pour compléter
sur les véhicules électriques et
notamment les automobiles électriques
les voitures électriques
nous avec l'agglomération souhaite
porter aussi à les chefs des douze
communes une réflexion globale et
surtout commune sur l'implantation de
bornes électriques
aujourd'hui chaque commune travaille un
petit peu de son côté et donc l'idée
pour nous aujourd'hui c'est d'avancer
sur ce sujet là ensemble notamment pour
qu'on ait à terme un maillage
territorial qui permettent de créer les
conditions aussi comme le disait madame
stefan d'une phase 2 voire peut-être
mais après d'une phase iii de
déploiement conséquent de ce type de
mobilité et xavier de la porte il y a
des communes avec paris on take qui
envisageront déjà mis en place des
centres ville piéton pour juste la
mobilité verte on va dire est ce que ça
pourrait être pensé aussi sur saint
quentin en yvelines
vous me posez une colle je pense que
c'est plus fictivement aux acteurs
politiques d'y répondre dans notre rôle
en tout cas ces deux c'est de permettre
de donner l'outil aux acteurs politiques
de pouvoir le décider au bon moment et
lorsque cela la situation s'y prêtera en
en mettant effectivement des encore une
fois des outils ou des systèmes de
mobilité qui seront accessibles
accessible facilement de façon à
vraiment limité l'utilisateur à ne pas
être obligé de prendre son propre
véhicule
c'est ça l'enjeu abandonné appartement
vous êtes sûr de pouvoir bouger vous
pourrez commencer à réfléchir autrement
votre déplacement que ça soit un
véhicule électrique encore une fois je
le dis que notre piètre mais tout
simplement d'aller d'aller à pied d'un
point à l'autre alors après 50 ans cest
une grande c'est une grande
agglomération
il ya beaucoup de communes il ya d'après
mais il peut y avoir plusieurs
kilomètres la voiture reste encore un
outil important
par contre il ya une réflexion qui peut
se faire et que les scores pouvoir la
faire c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous on
travaille en boucle fermée c'est un peu
lorsqu'on prend une voiture on leur
amène forcément à ça à sa station de
départ mais avec l'usagé ou la création
de nouvelles stations
ou pour aller vers un mode qu'on appelle
le one way c'est à dire réserver une
voiture sera point de départ par exemple
sur le centre de saint quentin
et puis aller sur une autre commune de
saint quentin qui aura disposera de deux
stations ski cher et laisser sa voiture
pour qu'elle soit prise ou réservées par
un autre par une autre personne
et à partir du moment où on aura
suffisamment de stations et mais là on
pourra encore une fois rajouté des
usages qui permettront aux gens de
vraiment limité l'usagé leur voiture
personnelle parce qu'on aura on sera
capable de manier le territoire de 51
mais bien avec toutes ses
caractéristiques est juste en quelques
secondes dans des intestins monique
puisqu'on parlait des pouvoirs
politiques
votre avis sur les propos du dossier de
la porte
non mais je partage totalement et je
dirais même qu'il ya il ya un autre
enjeu on a peut-être l'impression qu'on
est moins concernée sur saint-quentin
parce que ça reste quand même une
agglomération où vous avez cette gare 90
lignes de bus même s'il ya des besoins
évidemment autres en termes de mobilité
qui s'expriment mais n'oublions pas les
territoires les plus enclavées les plus
ruraux il ya des territoires je le
disais périurbain quand même sur le
territoire de l'agglomération je pense à
la commune une ville proche de penser à
magny les hameaux il y en a d'autres
et là il faut qu'on adapte nos
initiatives nos innovations aussi à la
réalité du terrain
ça c'est un enjeu aussi il ya l'enjeu
écologique l'enjeu climatique est
l'enjeu de désenclavement des
territoires les plus désolé des plus les
plus éloignés des différentes commodités
et ça je crois que l'innovation
technologique le progrès dans
l'immobilité c'est quelque chose qui
pourra répondre à cela et je ne vois pas
d'autre façon de faire que en
partenariat avec le monde économique et
avec les entreprises et c'est sur ces
mots qu'on va s'arrêter ça c'est une
société maintenant terminé merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]